[Music]
I'd like to treat it I guess
honestly
honestly if the answer like I'd like to
be treated with honesty
I'd want them to be treating me in the
way that you know I guess they view
themselves on their best day
you know when you come home at the end
of the day like when you have a good day
what like how do people treat you that
day I guess as an equal contributor to
society
like what my role in society is
[Music]
everyone should be given that
really want people to treat me with
understanding that I have my own life in
the diamond my own human being who are
going about their life
because people need to take a second to
put that their life aside and realize
that there are a bunch of other key
I would like to be treated like a
goddess like
like a sacred woman
like when to be yeah if it's like a
stranger I wouldn't care how it would be
treated because all you see I don't care
what a stranger thinks about me unless
it's someone I care about but
yeah like there's someone I care about
treat me like [ __ ] I would that's like
the worst piece just don't be mean
any reasons not necessary a generally
good person you know help people where
you can
it's always nice to feel wanted or you
know somebody useful it's they're really
good to you know put something down or
you know treat them the way you know you
wouldn't want to be treated that's kind
of my general philosophy I would like to
be treated kindly I suppose yeah with
empathy
that's about it however polite and
patient and courteous you treat your
pains or someone that you like had even
the littlest compassion for I feel like
that should be spread across all the
population I'd like to treat it just
like the way you want to be treated
wherever you are I think it's important
to validate everybody and if other
people were willing to do that then the
place would be probably a little cooler
I don't know I might want to like hang
out more I hang out enough but I'd hang
out more people were actually trying to
look out for each other
just be left alone really I'd like to be
treated pretty - I mean if you cheer
with me I'll be chilled with you I'm a
show person when
and a lot of respect
just genuine
then you're in my feelings
that's me
respect and kindness
I like the other person to regard me as
equal to the my god just treat me as
favorite for me to
are we treated like a lady with respect
with kindness with love
very kindly
kindness and respect with respect as an
equal and with respect faith
with respect
all of our respects definitely with
respect and kindness and generosity
Oh how would I like to be treated well I
mean it's almost a little too easy you
know I did you know the old golden rule
and you know isn't that the first thing
and everybody says we want to be treated
like you you want to be treated as you
treat others etc well mostly well
depends
[Music]
it depends depends on a lot of things a
lot more than you could get to in two
minutes what's your name Andrew and
where are you from Australia okay so the
question for today is can you describe
in detail how you would like to be
treated
in detail it doesn't need a lot of these
really just compassionate understand
if everybody treated at each other the
way they would like to be treated
themselves before
[Music]
my mama
before I was born
you got a poor child coming
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]